hier sieht man mich hier ziehe und leute
was geht ab ich habe ja gesagt ich mache
mir oder 1 heute und einst morgen oder
übermorgen und ein überübermorgen und
wir sind ja wir sind jetzt im auto und
die habe ich schon getroffen und ich
habe da noch facebook star getroffen
wir sind jetzt gerade ihren grund morgen
kommt mir da und wer glaubt nach liebe
leute eigentlich nicht sein dürfen oder
com zu einem neuen video oder das volk
hasst
wobei ich denke bin ja ist es richtig
geil hier und jetzt gleich hat machen
soll
meet and greet und mal gucken wer mich
da das nächste mal sind jetzt andere
auf jeden fall es ist ich hätte niemals
gedacht
möchten wir mit dem 1
und schon
auf der grand prix auf jeden fall
zufrieden
ja ich weiß kann weil ein gewitter und
schon ganz gut aufnimmt
ein minimum
da kann ich zu sehen
noch unklar
kannst du irgendwas passiert so die
kritik
mein pferd können musst du einfach wie
die mine zu schicken
hätte zwei tagen
die leute ja ich bin jetzt wieder zu
hause nach 12 5 oder so und es ist ja
schon 11 uhr und morgen geht es um 6 uhr
wieder los und warum 7 und deswegen muss
jetzt recht wenn ich heute zudem das
video sei auf jeden fall was richtig
geil heute und jetzt nicht mehr so viel
film aber geteilt mega ab hat mich echt
krass gewundert
ich freue mich schon auf morgen und ja
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
daumen hoch und in samokow alles in der
video beschreibung und wir sehen uns
dann morgen oder übermorgen wieder